what is our
objective today
we have to make sure that
refugees and displaced come back home
no matter where they
where they look for the refuge they and
shelter we have to
keep them interested
and
capable of coming back to ukraine
we can create a historic
precedent
in the earlier days when the aggressor
was fighting against
other countries he was
thinking
that
the ukraine's back will be broke but we
have uh proven that it is not possible
to break
ukraine this is why it's a key moment
for ukrainians to come back uh
possibility come because
ukraine educates europe is going through
one of the largest migration fights
because of war in ukraine
during several months only
12 million people
have left their homes what was the last
time this happened in the past the only
thing i can remember is the second world
war and that was a deliberate
act half a million in mario paul
hundred thousand
several the net 22 in walnut
this is the population of those cities
but russia described everything there
will truly
with the aviation and missiles they
didn't really
uh
were discrete in doing this so that i
can
name thousands
uh
hundreds of places that were destroyed
and dozens that are still
under threats
now russia is trying to pull back their
forces to to to organize their forces to
occupy
parking we have to occupy already and
they want to come back
again and that's one and a half million
citizen city they keep bombarding the
city of america alive and there's almost
half a million
uh citizen city they want to
occupy slavyansk and it was 100 000
city before the war of course we will do
our best to stop the occupiers and to
protect the people but to do it faster
we need your support we need more than
weaponry uh open a weaponry that would
have better capability than the russian
weapons and this is why i'm
using so many emotions and times and
efforts to
convince all of our partners to
transfer to us powerful
pieces of weaponry this is
the matter of life and death and the
second
question is
economy
while russian missiles are hitting our
cities it is not possible to
have a normal economic life
almost half of our economy our economic
system is not operational
just imagine
what would it mean if half of the
italian econ
economy would be black would be
blocked in particular
your industrial
uh elements none of the
your countries would be able to
stand against this without the support
we when we are saying we need about five
billion
dollars a month to uh
fill the deficit gap it's not about
money it's about
the number of ukrainians who would uh be
able to continue living during these
times
in ukraine
and the third item is rebuilding
we have to do
everything possible
so that after the victory
which will come undoubtedly
we could restore normal livelihoods in
the areas where russian occupiers were
trying to
leave only ruins behind
and
not just sanctions not just physical
losses of russian army in the
battlefield but the fact that life will
be restored in ukraine
the livelihood
would be a priority the fact that we can
come back
from ashes and the aggressor will be
left with losses and degradation
our goal
is for this migration crisis in europe
caused by the russian war of course and
only by russian war
would become
the last
crisis of its source so that no any
other grassroots future could think that
by using
war instruments he could just destroy
the life of any european
countries so the weaponry the financial
support and the rebuilding of ukraine
are three elements that
have to trigger the change but this is
not all we need to do
russian
war against us have triggered also a
global food crisis and unless we stop
this
12 million
displaced people will be just a drop in
the sea when new migration processes
will start
uh i just uh addressed the
representatives of the african union
before this and i was emphasizing the
food security
ukraine can supply
food
products to satisfy the critical
demands and for countries
in africa asia latin america without our
experts
there is a global deficit and that could
lead to
political economic and migration chaos
and
it is only this year that we have to do
everything
to make sure that the next year we would
need
we won't need to discuss
on this day
of refugees
the face of
many more
millions of refugees in the countries
that in europe and that border with
europe
today
the decisions of uh european
politicians uh determine
the future of many countries whether we
will have peace in ukraine uh or not
and whether we will be addressing these
uh challenges that we have talked today
about and i do want you to be very
active i'm very grateful
to italy for your principal position but
we do even more for ukraine to win
i would like to repeat
weapon
financial support and rebuilding of
ukraine are three elements that can make
a difference globally
thank you
for your attention love premium